[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum view cars dem
philosophischen podcast heute haben wir
den gast dieter frey bei uns herr
professor dr dieter frey
sie sind aktuell leiter des centers for
leadership and people management und
waren inhaber des lehrstuhls für
sozialpsychologie am department für
psychologie der lmu münchen
zudem sind sie seit vielen jahren in
wissenschaft und wirtschaft als berater
und trainer zu den themen führung
motivation und innovation aktiv sie sind
mitglied der bayerischen akademie der
wissenschaften und wurden 1998 zum
deutschen psychologie preisträger
gewählt und sie werden regelmäßig von
magazinen wie derzeit oder dem br
befragt wenn es um fragen zum thema
führung geht nun die frage an sie was
bedeutet denn gute führung sehr gute
führung bedeutet dass man ziele erreicht
probleme löst visionen er kommt aber
nicht alleine sondern die menschen
mitnimmt
und dabei muss man menschen überzeugen
man muss einen sinn vermitteln im
extremfall muss man menschen begeistern
die ziele die man gemeinsam erarbeitet
hat zu erreichen
sie haben sie auch kurz angesprochen
aber vielleicht gehen wir noch ein
bisschen näher darauf ein
denn sie sind ein starker vertreter der
ethischen führung wie es diese genau zu
verstehen und wie funktioniert sie ich
glaube dass man führung sehr einfach auf
den punkt bringen kann
letztlich geht es um die herstellung von
drei kulturen nämlich einer sogenannten
exzellenz kultur eine leistungskultur
einer innovationskultur oder auch eine
kultur von nachhaltigkeit
denn egal ob wir uns über führungen im
krankenhaus im altersheim in der schule
in der universität in einer in einem
betrieb unterhalten es geht schon um
qualität und leistung um innovation um
exzellenz
die zweite kultur wäre aber eine kultur
von wertschätzung also im menschen
liefern ja exzellenz und leistungen
innovationen also besteht eine kultur
des respekts der wertschätzung und die
dritte kultur die wir für wichtig halten
nennen wir kultur der ethik orientierten
führung das heißt vorbild verantwortung
verpflichtung vertrauen und deshalb kann
führung im kindergarten in der schule im
krankenhaus in den firmen relativ
einfach sein in führung begriffen hat
dass sie verantwortung übernehmen
vorbild sein müssen vertrauen geben
müssen und letztlich auch sich
verpflichtet fühlen müssen zwei kulturen
zu etablieren nämlich in einer
excellence kultur verbunden mit einer
wertschätzung skulptur denn die personen
die sich nicht gewehrt jetzt fühlen
die aktivierende potenzial nicht sondern
gehen vielleicht in den regionen machen
diesmal vor schlecht schritt ethisch
deshalb weil es um ganz zentrale
prinzipien wie wertschätzung wie respekt
wie fairness gerechtigkeit geht aber ich
glaube es ist auch ein ethisches prinzip
gute qualität und leistung zu bringen
wer möchte schon in einem krankenhaus
seien und wo jede zweite operation
schief geht wenn wir schon bei dem thema
ethik sind beziehungsweise sie haben
auch ganz speziell ein buch geschrieben
über die philosophie der führung
können sie dazu noch ein paar punkte
sagen ja wenn wir unsere praxis dreieck
nehmen mit den drei kulturen dann
verbirgt sich hinter der exzellenz
kultur mit sicherheit karl popper mit
seinem kritischen rationalismus wo das
zieles durch kritisch rationale
diskussion und durch forschung die
bestehenden theorien zu verbessern zu
verbessern zu verbessern
also insofern spielt die idee von
exzellenz bei karl popper da kann ich
nachher noch was sagen ja eine starke
wichtigkeit die zweite kultur nämlich
das prinzip von wertschätzung und
respekt geht eigentlich zurück auf
immanuel kant ja der sagt behandle den
gegenüber respektvoll und wenn du nicht
respektvoll behandelt fühlst
reagierenden selbstrespekt urin hat also
die idee des respekt des sohnes selbst
respektes dieselbe relevanz also hab'
keine allzu hohen respekt vor der vor
der hierarchie vor der kirche vor dem
start sondern respektiere die menschen
keine ist ja immer kann er von pfarrer
hier respekt vor menschen und die dritte
kultur mit verantwortung würde ich auf
hans jonas beziehen
der berühmteste verantwortung für das
oft der gesagt hat wir sind
verantwortlich einerseits für
menschenwürde auf dieser welt aber
gleichzeitig auch für diesen planeten
ja das heißt man kann unsere kulturen
die für relevante führung verantwortlich
sind in der tat auf philosophen
zurückführen und von diesen philosophen
können wir sehr viel lernen
überspitzt gesagt würde sagen wer die
grundideen von kant popper und jonas
beherrscht und umsetzt und lebt wird
letztlich auch eine organisation haben
bei der sich die leute wohlfühlen und
die erfolgreich sein wird weil sie
bestimmte ziele von exzellenz von
innovation nachhaltigkeit erreichen wird
wahnsinnig interessanter gedanke ja was
können wir denn jetzt
in bezug auf die großen philosophen
derzeit oder in bezug auf führungen im
heutigen zeitalter noch lernen
streng genommen kein wahres daraus
lernen
also nehmen wir noch mal auf unsere drei
philosophen oder nehmen wir vor allem
für mich ist opa und kannte es in die
wichtigsten wenn wir über innovationen
reden ja dann spielt poker natürlich
eine ganz zentrale rolle dinge infrage
stellen dinge franz fietz ihren kritisch
rationale diskussion kampf den
dogmatismus sondern offene systeme haben
in seinem buch die die die offene
gesellschaft und ihre und ihre feinde
sagt er ja dass das der dogmatismus der
der der feind des bestehenden es und wir
brauchen eben eine offene kultur in den
firmen und oft erlebe ich dass firmen
oder universitäten sehr totalitär
organisiert sind kein widerspruch und
kritisches denken querdenken nicht
erlaubt werde und das ist natürlich der
feind jeder innovation ja und kant
allein wenn wir die ganze idee von
respekt betrachten und bediene dich
deines eigenen verstandes also damit die
macht des arguments die macht der
individuellen des individuellen
verbesserungsvorschlag soll jeder
ermunterte bringen eine verbesserung zu
bedienen dich deines eigenen verstandes
denn du bist an der basis du kannst hast
wenn man allein diese beiden in den
umsätzen sind auf den prozess zur
innovation der notwendig ist in der
wissenschaft aber auch in der wirtschaft
vielen dank also wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe sind die großen denker
und seit heute aktueller denn je
sie sind deshalb aktuell weil sie die
werte vorgegeben haben die wichtig sind
zum beispiel exzellenz und laufende
verbesserung
auch die werte von wertschätzung
die psychologie kann dann definieren wie
setzt man es um erreiche ich die
menschen dass sie diese werde für
wichtig erachten und mit welchen ja mit
welchem handlungsanleitungen überzeugen
sie menschen dass sie exzellenz zeigen
dass die wertschätzung zeigen wie löst
man die konflikte dann exzellenz und
wirtschaft bedeutet oft einen konflikt
da gibt es auch wieder ist eigentlich
der psychologe der das wissen hat und
die handlungskompetenzen wie man diese
minimieren kann und das finde ich eben
eine schöne verbindung zwischen
philosophie die die werte vor gibt diese
programmieren und der psychologie die
sehr viel know-how entwickelt wie man
dieses erreichen kann
danke vielen dank für diesen wirklich
spannenden denkanstoß und vielen dank
für den tollen einblick in die
philosophie der führung und auf die
antworten oder auf die frage was gute
führung bedeutete vielen dank herr
professor doktor frei
[Musik]